Yeah. People are telling her in the chat
to let me up.
Do you know logic? Yeah, don't don't
ever bring this guy up. He's a
blasphemer of Islam. He
endorses people ripping the Quran,
eating the Quran, burning the Quran.
Your religion also commands that
apostates like myself should be
executed. So 100% yes. I would actually
advise for you to block him.
100% halal and stay
>> [music]
>> very very far from him. He is a filth of
an individual.
100% halal. These Dawah dudes are some
of the biggest cowards that you can ever
come across. Every time I show up, this
man heart races. Here's my name when he
sees that I'm in his vicinity. The Dawah
guys, block him. Never let him up. I
advise you he's a blasphemer. He's a
sick evil individual. Well, the only
thing I do is read, huh?
Uh let's talk about something else. You
You down to talk about Paul versus
Muhammad? Nope. No, we You You yourself
know that Paul was a annihilator. Yeah,
he was. And he changed his he changed
his ways.
Yeah, but Muhammad was Muhammad was
Muhammad was a Jew. He was a Jew and
Christian annihilator. All right. All
right, get off my panel, bro. Oh, what?
Oh,
in the in the cause of Allah and I will
believe is is it in the cause of Allah?
You see? Notice how you have an you have
a you have a justification for what
Muhammad is doing. I can say that Paul
was wrong for killing Christians and
imprisoning Christians. Can you say that
Muhammad was wrong for killing Jews and
going out to attack Christians?
So you can say that because it's your
belief, right? The Prophet Muhammad to
Islam he was known as being righteous
and trustworthy, never lying and having
upright character. Everybody trusted
him. So when the when the message came,
people believed him. Muhammad had no
witnesses to his revelation in the cave,
but Paul had witnesses to his
revelation. He had the soldiers that was
with him. He also had Ananias who also
received a revelation that confirmed
Paul's revelation that he received on
the road to Damascus. Did anybody else
like just Did anybody have a revelation
that confirmed Muhammad's revelation?
>> Uh no, he's the only one getting
revelations. So how would anybody else
get a revelation? got you. Think about
this with me. What do you think is more
credible?
A person who doesn't have witnesses
claiming to have experienced something
solely on his own
or someone
who does have witnesses to what he
experienced and not just witnesses, but
divine witnesses, revelation
that confirms what he experienced.
>> Divine witnesses?
Yeah, yeah. I'm saying you're
>> [snorts]
>> See uh oversimplification is a form of
manipulation. Let's say all my 30 years
of living, I've been known to have never
lied. I've been known to be trustworthy.
I've been known to do good to the poor.
I've been known to be a really good
person. And then I came out and said,
"Hey guys, God gave me a revelation.
Gave me a revelation. He came to me and
and now I am a prophet of God." Would
that Would that mean Would that mean
that I'm telling the truth? Does that
Does that make sense what I'm saying to
you?
>> Yeah, yeah. The your reputation
with the community that you have never
did this is a proof for the community.
If you go in a court, right? And there's
multiple people testifying. The most
reliable
uh testimonies are a form of Well,
testifiers are a form of proof. Well,
if the defendant has witnesses to
cooperate what he says, where he's been,
his story, and so on and so forth. He
has witnesses testifying to back up what
he said. The accuser has no witnesses.
It's just him saying It's just his own
word of mouth. In the courtroom, which
case is more credible? The defendant
with witnesses or the accuser with no
witnesses? How the hell you going to
witness a dream? How How the hell people
going to witness Could God Could God
Could God Could God give someone a dream
that cooperate somebody else's dream?
Is that a Is that Yeah, of course. But
is that a witness to a dream? Yeah,
it'll be a witness to the dream. But God
Do you Are you familiar with the story
of Daniel? No, I'm not familiar with it.
Okay. Daniel [clears throat] was a
prophet of God.
He was in Babylon and he used to serve
King Nebuchadnezzar.
Nebuchadnezzar had a really terrible
dream.
Nobody could interpret the dream, but
Daniel he came
Daniel came
and he told he told Nebuchadnezzar what
his dream was and interpreted it by
God's by God's gift of revelation. Could
you agree with me that Daniel is a
witness to the dream Nebuchadnezzar had?
Because God gave him revelation of of
his dream. No. No? Okay.
I'm going to leave I'm going to leave
you to yourself, man. Keep Enjoy Islam,
bro. Copy, bro. Will do. Absolute idiot.
Absolute idiot. Guys, Islam is a is a
fungus. He He's a human being made in
the image of God just like you and me.
And you you can't you can't accept sense
in Islam. You can't accept
logic in Islam. You cannot accept what
is clear. You can't accept clarity in
Islam. That's That's Islam, y'all.
Saying that uh is not a response. The
way that Jesus demonstrated his
divinity, one is the claims that he
made, claiming to be the first and the
last, claiming to be the giver of
eternal life, claiming to be the one who
forgives sins or is has the authority to
give somebody else the ability to
forgive sins in his name, given other
people the ability to do miracles. He
did this and he proved that he is what
he said he is. Not just by claiming it,
but by doing it. He gave the apostles
the ability to do the works and miracles
to show that they were sent by him. He
poured out the spirit the Holy Spirit on
them, giving them miraculous the
disciples miraculous powers. And he rose
himself from the dead like he said he
would. So everything he said about
himself was vindicated by the works that
followed and the proofs. Okay. So here
all you've done so far Yes, sir. is
mention the same two things which don't
make you God. Oh. Did Jesus give
miracles?
So So did the apostles do miracle
working power through the authority and
power of Jesus? Yes, the authority that
was given to him. Given to them Well,
well,
who gave the apostles the authority and
the ability to do miracles? Jesus Christ
through God almighty. Don't Don't say
that. It was the miracle It was the
miracle of God. It doesn't make the one
receiving it God. It makes the one who
sent it God. Back to the source. I like
that. I like what you just said. It
makes the one who sent it God. Who sent
the apostles these miracles? God. Okay.
I I like that. I see See, I and and I
agree with you. God from the heavens.
Who did Peter say when he healed the the
lame person uh in the middle of the
marketplace? I'm going to have to bring
you the verse. It reads, "But Peter
said, 'I have no silver [clears throat]
and gold, but I give you what I have in
the name of Jesus Christ of Nazareth,
walk.'"
Okay. "And his name by faith in his name
has made this man strong whom you see
and know, and the faith which is through
Jesus has given this man or given the
man this perfect health in the presence
of you all." So you have no problem with
According to Peter, who did he say is
[snorts] the one who is through his
power and by his might and by his name,
his authority, that the miracle was
done? By his authority and by his might.
This one would be referring to Jesus
Christ. Awesome. And so now look,
we have a common ground. Our common
ground that we established is that it's
God who gives the miracles. God is the
one who gives the miracles, no one else.
So the fact that even Peter says that
this miracle isn't done by me, but it's
Jesus who gave this miracle. This means
and demonstrates that Jesus is God even
according to the standard we set. I
heard something about man worshiper. I
didn't hear the part before that. Well,
yeah. Yeah, I said why would I debate a
man worshiper like like you down here?
We worship the heaven the God of the
heavens and the earth. The man worshiper
is way down here like But you worship a
man, though. I'm confused. How you
telling me what I worship? That don't
make no sense. You're a Muslim, right?
>> Yeah, I'm a Muslim. We worship the God
of the heavens and the earth. No, you
don't. You worship a man who claims to
be the God of the heaven and the earth.
I know it's not what you believe. The
point is is that that's what your Quran
teaches.
However way you want, but no person who
read the Quran and no Muslim
know that Muslims don't worship a man.
Like this is common knowledge. Would you
agree that
uh that men need a mate in order to have
a son? That men need a mate in order to
have a son. Yeah, that's what that's
what people need. How you Yeah. Well,
the Quran says that same thing about
Allah. It says Allah needs a mate in
order to have a son.
>> Anything Anything needs an equal to have
a a child.
>> Yeah, sounds like a man to me. Sounds
like just like a man. That's that's a
man. God doesn't need no equal in order
to have a son. He can just have a son of
his own substance, but Allah needs a man
just like I mean I'm sorry. Allah needs
a mate just like any man does. That's
Allah. Allah also needs exactly what man
needs in order to have a son. So you you
worship a man, but you're accusing
others of being man worshipers. You're
no different than what you're accusing
other people of being. When Allah poses
a question to disbelievers,
they don't answer the question. He
already done
>> He's asking a logical question. How was
he going to So how was he going to have
a son Mhm. if he does not have a mate?
Sure.
I I can I can answer that. Yeah, I can I
can answer that. But notice what I'll
give you the answer and then I'll show
you. Don't Don't deny it. I'll show you
what I
I'll give you the answer. God can have a
son from his own substance. He can beget
a son from his own substance without any
help, without the need of a mate. He can
beget from his own substance. He doesn't
need help cuz he's God. He's all
powerful.
But Allah, he's not actually challenging
you to answer the question. He's
actually refuting the logic of the
humans who are saying that he has
children. He's saying, "How can I have a
son when I don't have a mate?" So Allah
himself is making it clear that he
cannot have a son without a mate, just
like how humans can't have children
without mates. He's just like us.
>> This is you putting together words, but
from his substance, what what what is
what consists of his substance, right?
What is his substance? Eternality, all
powerfulness, knowledge.
>> Okay, boom. All of that.
>> Boom. All of this stuff?
>> Boom, all right. He can have a son from
his own from his own substance, but
Allah can't. He's He's just like
>> Boom boom boom. Did you answer my
question already? Being eternal, being
all powerful, you said these two. Now,
does a son have to does a son take on a
trait? Like a offspring, do they take on
traits of the substance?
Okay, that's impossible. You can't have
a son You can't have
Someone can't have also have a trait of
eternity. Now that's two That's two
eternities. That's impossible. No, it's
one eternity, just two distinct persons
who share that same eternity. That's
all.
But if he be God,
then he had a son, he begot him. So it's
not just two eternities.
>> It would It would have to be something
>> eternity and then he begot, right?
>> be
It would be something
>> So now that's two eternities. It would
be something done not in time.
God can beget outside of time, which
would mean it's an eternal action that
happens, not something that takes place
in time.
What What There we go There we go with
logic. There we go with logic. You just
saying You saying, "Okay, now you have a
son out of out of time." Now Yeah. So
you still answering the same question.
So then you have to So then you Brother,
you have to deal with then if you're
going to reject that and say, "No uh no
uh no uh." That's fine. You can hold
your position.
Then you have to answer for Allah being
incapable of having a son without a
mate, just like men do.
You're saying that you're you're going
against men worshipers, but all
everything in the Quran is showing me
that Allah's a man like us. It means
that your overall thing is capable. The
more you're capable to do whatever
anything can do, you can you're more
capable of doing.
>> Absolutely, and you don't need any help.
You're not dependent on anything to do
anything that you want to do, right?
>> Uh that's uh that's would be
self-sustaining. Right, which would mean
all powerful. You In order to be all
powerful, you have to be
self-sustaining, correct?
>> Uh yep yep. Okay.
>> So that would be
So So to be all powerful means that you
are capable of doing all things. Nothing
is too hard for you, and you don't need
help doing it. Okay? Now, here's part
two.
Allah doesn't fit that category because
Allah cannot have a son
by himself. Allah would need help in
order to have a son. So therefore, he
does not have the quality of all
powerfulness. He's not all powerful.
Having a son is not a a powerful thing.
This is not something begetting children
that's that doesn't go into power. My
argument is not that, "Oh, he has to
have a son in order to be powerful."
>> [laughter]
>> My argument is that he couldn't have a
son by himself even if he wanted to. He
would need help. So if you need help to
do something, if you need if you depend
on something outside of yourself
for something, then you're not all
powerful. You're not self-sustaining.
You mis- You mis- You're misrepresenting
the Quran and what what Allah is saying.
Okay, can Allah have a son by himself or
You You saying You saying You saying he
needs help to have a son. The point is
there's no point of having a son, right?
That's not the point at all, bro. The
point is can he do it?
Can he do it by himself? Could he do it?
If he could, he would have chosen from
one of his creation. That's fine. And he
didn't even do that. But could he do it?
Could he do it by himself? You You
saying have offspring. You cannot have
offspring without a mate. Okay, so Allah
>> That's what offspring is.
>> you. So it's a it's a child. It's
something of yourself. So Allah cannot
have a son No, that's not what offspring
is. without Hold on. Allah cannot have a
son
without help.
In order for him to have a son, he would
need help, something outside of himself
in order to help him to have a son.
Therefore, he's dependent and not all
powerful. He's a limited being.
So he he's not God. He does not have the
God substance.